wissen sie wir arbeiten hier für unsere
hart zur bevölkerung für die menschen
die hier leben und nicht für einzelne
politiker den startschuss geben wollen
oder ein bändchen durchschneiden
das ist unsere verpflichtung und dem
wollen sie auch nachkommen haben sie das
gefühl dass die politik das so ein
bisschen als schon jetzt nutzen wollte
heute die dem staat also ich sehe
zumindest keinen medizinischen oder
logistischen grund hier ein solches 10
robert zu veranstalten sondern wir sind
so aufgestellt wenn wir die
einsatzbereitschaft haben wollen wir
auch loslegen hier ist eine sehr hohe
motivation in dem team
und auch bei der bevölkerung sie haben
auch gesagt die bevölkerung auch hier im
herzen möchte die entfernen hat ein
großes interesse und daher sehen wir es
tatsächlich nicht ein den impfstoff
vorzuenthalten nur weil eine
pressekonferenz anberaumt wird zum
abschluss her kam
erklären sie uns doch mal wie dramatisch
ist die situation in den altenheim in
den pflegeheim was erleben sie das
wirklich
also wir sehen natürlich den großen
wunsch der bewohner und auch der
mitarbeiter den impfstoff zu erhalten
alle sind tatsächlich davon überzeugt
und wir haben bis heute sehr positives
feedback bekommen für den start den wir
ihrem arzt gezeigt haben dass jeder tag
wirklich zählt und wir müssen auch
einfach daran denken dass wir es den
leuten auch erklären müssen warum hier
impfstoff künstlich zurückgehalten wird
wir müssen vielleicht auch die frage
stellen warum waren niemand anderes
bereit diese entscheidung zu treffen
sehr frühzeitig zu beginnen wenn der
impfstoff vor ort ist